hey what's up guys now so many of you
asked me hey Daniel how can I increase
my height or how can I grow taller but
can anything be done about it
well I'm gonna tell you so let's start
the video
[Music]
hey welcome to D LM model lifestyle I'm
Daniel and if you're new here please
subscribe and click the notification
bell so you won't miss any new videos
now what determines your height research
shows there are two main things that
determines your height the one is
genetics the other is environmental
factors like diet now around 60 to 80
percent of your height is determined by
genetics so you can't really do anything
about it right but around twenty to
forty percent of your height is
determined by environmental factors and
you can do something about your
environmental factors that will help you
to grow taller so I'm gonna give you a
few tips to help you increase your
height number one is always have a
balanced diet so eat a lot of protein
like eggs poultry soy fish and good
dairy products that help your bones grow
healthy and also your muscles also eat
more calcium that is found in food like
green vegetables such as spinach kale
dairy products and so on and then get
more vitamin D which helps bone and
muscle growth in kids now this is very
important because if you do not get
enough vitamin D then it can also stunt
your growth and it can also cause weight
gain in girls now vitamin D can be found
in certain foods like fish and mushrooms
and even in some milks and you can also
get it from the Sun so go outside a
little bit more and let the sunlight do
its job
alright number two is exercise more if
you exercise a lot more in your teenage
years then it can help you to grow
taller with proper supervision and just
learning the right techniques working
out and just lifting some weights is
safe for all ages so go and join a gym
or a sports team just to get more
exercise number three get more sleep you
actually grow a lot more when you sleep
so if you're younger than 20 try to get
between nine and eleven hours of sleep
because getting in a good amount of
sleep will produce more HGH which is
your growth hormone all right number
four is stop using stuff that will stunt
your growth is a lot of people under the
age of twenty that uses things that
stunt their growth without even knowing
it
like for example drugs and alcohol both
of them are thought to contribute to
stunt growth and hey just so you know
there's a lot of people out there that
believe if you use caffeine when you're
young it's stunts your growth that's
actually just a myth yeah it's not true
it's not enough scientific evidence that
backs it up
but steroids yes that can absolutely
stunt your growth
now anabolic steroids inhibits bone
growth in children and in teens as well
it also lowers the sperm count breast
size and even put you at a higher risk
for heart attack another example is
smoking now smoking or children exposed
to second-hand smoking are also proven
to stunt their growth so if there are
some adults listening to this video stop
smoking in front of your kids
alright now some of you ask me hey can
you increase your height after 18 well
the truth is that for most people your
height will not increase after around 18
to
even if you do all these tips that I
just talked about it's probably not
gonna happen why well it's because your
growth plates in your bones close near
the end of puberty the hormonal changes
causes the growth plates to kind of
harden or close and then it stopped the
lengthening of your bones and that's why
you cannot grow any taller now if you
are still unhappy about your height what
can you do
what are the options well number one
practice good posture if you have a bad
posture you will look even shorter but
if your posture is better stand up
straight
head straight you will look taller
number two try heels or inserts all you
got to do is choose shoes with taller
heels or play some inserts inside your
shoes just to add a few inches number
three gain muscle to look and feel
bigger because if you feel small in
general lifting some weights to gain
muscle can make you more bigger and give
you more confidence number for
stretching and hanging it can reverse
the compression of your spine making you
slightly taller by one percent but only
until your spine compresses again so
it's not really a great tip but another
tip is to style your hair up if you
stall your hair up it gives the
impression that you're a little bit
taller as well all right now some people
might be happy with just some of these
strategies but everybody is not happy of
it so they resort to more extreme
measures like medical treatments now in
some of these treatments they lengthen
the bones of the lower leg but to me
these treatments are expensive and
evasive maybe that is why they are
banned in so many countries as well now
apart from these treatments there are
other people who are looking into the
treatments with the Grove
gah now though gah well it works in
children who struggles to grow but as
far as I know it's not gonna really help
adults but then again maybe you should
just do your own research and look into
it now honestly guys I believe that
finding a way to accept your height is a
lot better compared to doing extreme
measures instead focus more on your
other strengths because ultimately there
are a lot of stuff in this world that we
cannot change ourselves but we can
change how we think and how we react to
those situations and so we can always
strive to make the most of it alright
guys that's it if you liked the video
give it a thumbs up subscribe and that's
it Cheers
[Music]
you
[Music]